PREVIOUSLY ON...
NNENNA GAVE
HER JEALOUS BOYFRIEND...
Nnenna, did you kiss
on a guy?
SOMETHING TO WORRY ABOUT.
BROOKE FLOUNDERED
AT THE PHOTO SHOOT.
DOES THIS LOOK GOOD?
DOES IT SELL AN OUTFIT?
OKAY.
WHILE FURONDA TOOK CONTROL.
IT'S GOOD.
AND EVEN THOUGH GINA
CONFRONTED JADE...
YOU CAN SAY WHATEVER
THE HELL YOU WANT, JADE.
SHE LET IT AFFECT
HER PERFORMANCE ON SET
AND AT JUDGING.
IT'S NOT PERFECT WHERE
WE'RE LIVING RIGHT NOW,
AND I'M LETTING IT GET TO ME,
OBVIOUSLY.
IN THE END,
GINA WAS SENT HOME.
NINE GIRLS REMAIN.
WHO WILL BE ELIMINATED TONIGHT?
♪♪♪
GINA WAS IN THE BOTTOM TWO
THAT ONE WEEK. SHE GOT TO STAY.
THE NEXT WEEK, SHE'S GONE.
YEAH.
I WAS IN THE BOTTOM TWO
THIS WEEK.
THE NEXT WEEK,
I'M GONNA BE GONE.
NO.
WHAT DO I KNOW?
I'M NOT TYRA.
I WAS IN THE BOTTOM TWO
BECAUSE TYRA TELLS ME THAT
I HAVE ALL THIS POTENTIAL,
BUT I CANNOT TAKE
A GOOD PHOTOGRAPH.
BUT ALL THE JUDGES SEE
RIGHT NOW IS POTENTIAL.
BYE-BYE, BROOKEY.
LIKE, I ALMOST WANNA GO
INTO PANEL AND BE, LIKE,
"BEFORE YOU SAY ANYTHING,
LET ME SHOW YOU SOME MOLLIE."
TYRA'S BEEN TELLING ME IN PANEL,
LIKE, "JUST SHOW US
YOUR PERSONALITY."
THE JUDGES AREN'T GETTING
A SENSE OF WHO YOU ARE.
MY PERSONALITY IS SO MUCH
A PART OF ME, AND, LIKE,
NO ONE'S SEEING IT.
"MOLLIE'S ALWAYS GOOFY.
SHE MAKES FUNNY FACES.
SHE FARTS."
BUT YOU CAN'T PLAN ANYTHING,
EITHER,
'CAUSE THAT'S WHEN I GO,
"DUH, DUH, DUH."
NNENNA'S ON THE PHONE.
SHOOT, DUDE.
I WENT TO SLEEP LAST NIGHT
REALLY, REALLY DEPRESSED,
AND THAT'S NOT FAIR.
Oh, yeah?
Well, think about how I felt
every night so far this month.
JOHN IS INSECURE
ABOUT CERTAIN THINGS
BECAUSE WE HAD A PHOTO SHOOT
WITH A MALE MODEL.
ALL RIGHT, NNENNA.
Don't do this to me.
I know something's up.
I know it, all right?
OKAY, JOHN, JOHN.
I DON'T WANT TO ARGUE ANYMORE.
THIS HAS GONE DIRTY ENOUGH.
IT'S ENOUGH.
ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
I DO CARE ABOUT HIM,
BUT I ALSO WANT TO KEEP MY FOCUS
FOR WHAT I'M HERE FOR.
I'M DONE. DONE.
RELATIONSHIP IS OVER.
ARE YOU SERIOUS?
IT'S OVER.
OH, MY GOD.
I DON'T HAVE A BOYFRIEND.
I'M FREE.
I HAVE NOTHING HOLDING ME BACK.
SO I LOVE HER TO DEATH,
BUT THAT'S GONNA HURT HER
IN THE END.
YOU FEEL WHAT I'M SAYING?
JADE IS THE TYPE OF PERSON--
IF SHE FEELS LIKE SHE'S FOUND
AN EASY TARGET,
SHE WORKS THAT FOR AS MUCH
AS SHE CAN WORK IT FOR,
LIKE SHE DID WITH GINA.
HERE, JUST KISS IT. COME ON.
KISS IT, KISS IT.
NO, IT'S OKAY.
THERE ARE A LOT OF PEOPLE
THAT ARE NOT WHAT THEY SAY
OR NOT WHAT THEY SEEM.
I DON'T THINK YOU SHOULD
BREAK UP WITH HIM.
BUT THEN AGAIN,
I'M NOT IN YOUR RELATIONSHIP.
I DON'T KNOW.
YEAH, I THINK JADE KNOWS.
SHE KNOWS WHAT SHE'S DOING.
WHAT GOES AROUND COMES AROUND.
SHE'S PLAYING A GAME TOO MUCH.
♪♪♪
HELLO!
HI!
HOW IS EVERYBODY?
GOOD.
ANY PRESSURE, ANYTHING?
WHAT'S THE HARDEST PART
OF BEING IN THIS COMPETITION?
NOT KNOWING WHAT'S
GONNA HAPPEN NEXT.
REALLY?
WELL, YOU GUYS ARE THE TOP NINE,
SO YOU'VE GOTTEN THIS FAR.
SO IS IT HARD WALKING
INTO THE JUDGING ROOM AND...
YES.
I'VE BEEN WORKING SO HARD.
I'M SO TIRED, YOU GUYS.
I FEEL...
I'M SO SORRY, YOU GUYS.
I DON'T MEAN TO BE
ALL WEAK IN FRONT OF YOU,
BUT I'M JUST SO LIGHT-HEADED.
SOMEBODY BRING SOME WATER.
GET SOME PIZZA?
SOME JUICE.
I'M ALL RIGHT.
NO! TYRA!
TYRA! PLEASE SAVE HER, Y'ALL!
OH, MY GOD.
WHAT'S HER PULSE?
CHECK HER PULSE.
I'M ALL RIGHT. I'M OKAY.
TODAY YOU GUYS
ARE GONNA LEARN ABOUT ACTING!
LEARN ABOUT ACTING!
ACTING! ACTING! ACTING!
THAT WAS FAKE!
THAT WAS A GOOD JOB.
GOOD JOB.
OH... ARE YOU OKAY?
I CAN'T DEAL WITH IT.
I THINK TYRA'S
TOO GOOD OF AN ACTRESS,
AND THAT WAS A VERY MEAN TRICK
THAT SHE PLAYED ON US.
WELL, I DID THAT BECAUSE
YOU GUYS ARE GONNA BE LEARNING
ALL ABOUT ACTING THIS WEEK,
AND IT'S ABOUT BEING CONVINCING,
AND IT'S ABOUT BEING REAL.
YOU HAVE TO BE ABLE
TO BE IN
A COMMERCIAL AND SAY THE WORDS
AND BE CONVINCING, ALL RIGHT?
SO THAT IS WHY I DID THIS,
TO SHOW YOU GOTTA GO FOR IT,
AND YOU GOTTA COMMIT.
TO MAKE UP FOR
WHAT I JUST DID TO YOU,
I HAVE THESE SHIRTS FOR YOU.
THIS IS A LITTLE GIFT FROM ME.
THANK YOU!
I WANT ALL OF YOU GUYS
TO SHINE.
TO BE GOOD ACTRESS-MODELS
AND MAKE
YOUR LITTLE MAMA PROUD.
SEE YA LATER!
BYE!
OH, MY GOODNESS.
I CANNOT ACT.
'CAUSE I'M SO GULLIBLE.
♪♪♪
HI, GUYS.
WELCOME TO THE GROUNDLINGS.
I'M JEREMY ROWLEY.
THIS IS AN IMPROV
AND SKETCH THEATER.
FROM THIS THEATER HAVE COME
A LOT OF
REALLY SUCCESSFUL PERFORMERS
LIKE WILL FERRELL,
LISA KUDROW,
JENNIFER COOLIDGE,
PEE-WEE HERMAN.
THIS IS COOL.
LIKE, FAMOUS PEOPLE THAT
ARE ON TV HAVE ORIGINATED HERE.
WE HAVE A LOT OF
DIFFERENT PEOPLE
TAKE OUR CLASSES,
INCLUDING TYRA BANKS.
AND SHE'S PERFORMED
ON THIS VERY STAGE
AS A CELEBRITY GUEST.
I ALWAYS WANTED TO TAKE
A PROFESSIONAL ACTING LESSON.
GIRL, I THINK I'M MADE
FOR THIS STAGE.
TODAY YOU'RE GOING TO BE
DOING SOME IMPROV GAMES
AND EXERCISES,
AND WE'RE GONNA HELP YOU
LET YOUR PERSONALITY
COME THROUGH.
I WAS REALLY EXCITED ABOUT IT
JUST 'CAUSE THIS IS GONNA
HELP ME IN PANEL.
THEY'RE GOING TO SEE
THAT I'M A GOOFBALL
WITHOUT THEM GOING,
"WHAT IS SHE DOING?"
I'M JUST GONNA ASK YOU
TO KIND OF THROW YOURSELF
INTO THE THING I ASK YOU TO DO
AND NOT JUDGE THE RESULT.
TERRIFIED! GO!
(screaming)
EXCELLENT!
AND NOW YOU'RE JANICE DICKINSON!
HOLLA!
GO!
(screeching)
ANGER!
KEEP MOVING AS YOU DO IT!
(shouting)
BACK TO NEUTRAL WALKING.
GOOD. THAT ONE WAS EASY.
ANGER WAS EASY, HUH?
SIMPLE EXERCISE LIKE THAT
IS GONNA HELP YOU
WITH YOUR MODELING.
PEOPLE ARE GONNA ASK YOU TO DO
SOME REALLY INTERESTING THINGS
IN A MODELING SHOOT,
AND THEY'RE GONNA WANT YOU
TO COMMIT TO IT.
CAN'T BE LIKE, "THIS IS CRAZY.
THIS IS STUPID," RIGHT?
NEXT THING WE'RE GONNA DO,
YOU'RE GONNA WORK AS A TEAM.
WE'RE GONNA
CREATE A STORY TOGETHER.
OKAY, THIS IS CALLED
"ONE NIGHT STAND."
DOMINIQUE WALKED
INTO THE NICE, WARM BEDROOM.
IMPROV WORRIES ME BECAUSE
YOU HAVE TO COME UP WITH THINGS
LIKE, OUT OF NOWHERE,
AND WHEN I'M PUT ON THE SPOT,
I BECOME REALLY NERVOUS.
WHERE HE SLATHERED BUTTER
ALL OVER LAMAR.
LITTLE MORE ENERGY,
MOLLIE SUE.
"THE PRINCESS AND HER DOGGIE."
(British accent)
THE PRINCESS' MOM
SAID THAT WALKING HER DOG
IS A DELIGHTFUL TREATMENT.
(foreign accent)
SHE WALKED HER DOG,
AND ONE DAY,
HE BECAME MAGICALLY INCLINED
TO TELL HER...
NOT WHILE SHE'S TALKING.
YOUR MOMENT INTERRUPTED
THE STORY, AND ALL OF A SUDDEN,
THE STORY DOESN'T
MAKE SENSE ANYMORE, RIGHT?
SOMETIMES IT'S NOT ABOUT YOU.
ALL RIGHT, LADIES,
I HOPE THAT THESE LESSONS
WILL CARRY WITH YOU,
AND YOU'LL USE SOME OF
THESE LITTLE TIPS AND TRICKS
WITH YOU OUT THERE,
SO THANKS VERY MUCH.
GET OUT OF HERE.
(laughter)
- THANK YOU.
- THANKS FOR COMING.
Nnenna, here's the problem.
HONEY, ENOUGH IS ENOUGH.
I NEED SOME SUPPORT.
I NEED TO BE MENTALLY PREPARED
AND WELL RESTED.
NNENNA HAS HAD NOTHING
BUT DRAMA WITH HER BOYFRIEND.
I'm on the edge right now.
YOU'RE EMBARRASSING ME.
HE'S CRYING ALL THE TIME.
(crying)
SHE'S SCREAMING AT HIM.
SO GET UP, JOHN. SERIOUSLY.
STOP.
I THINK IT'S BROUGHT OUT
A KIND OF A NEGATIVE SIDE
OF NNENNA.
YOU'RE ALREADY CRYING,
AND IT'S ANNOYING
AND MAKING ME ANGRY.
No, I wasn't crying.
IT'S MAKING ME ANGRY INSTEAD
OF MAKING ME SYMPATHETIC.
I'M ONLY GONNA HATE YOU
WHEN I GET BACK, I SWEAR TO GOD.
I'M TRYING TO BE FAIR.
JADE IS ADVISING NNENNA
TO, YOU KNOW, STAY WITH HER MAN.
"YOU NEED TO TRUST ME."
YOU NEED TO TRUST ME, JOHN.
I trust you.
I NEED YOU TO SUPPORT ME.
LOVE IS SUCH A DISTRACTION,
YOU KNOW?
IT'S A BEAUTIFUL THING,
BUT IT WILL KILL YOU.
♪♪♪
TYRA MAIL!
TYRA MAIL.
"DON'T BE AFRAID TO WILD OUT."
"WILD OUT"?
♪♪♪
AAH!
(laughter)
WHAT'S UP, GUYS?
HOW YOU DOING?
WHAT'S UP?
MY NAME IS NICK CANNON,
AND THESE ARE MY FRIENDS
AT CASA WILD 'N OUT--
LEONARD ROBINSON...
GOT MUSCLES.
NOT REALLY.
AND ROB HOFFMAN.
YOU CAN'T HAVE THIS.
"WILD 'N OUT" SHOW--
THAT'S JUST AN IMPROV SHOW
WHERE YOU HAVE TO BASICALLY
JUST BE FUNNY
ON THE SPUR OF THE MOMENT.
NOW WE KNOW YOU GUYS
DID YOUR THING
WITH THE GROUNDLINGS,
BUT NOW IT'S TIME
FOR YOUR
WILD 'N OUT CHALLENGE.
WE'RE GONNA PLAY A FEW GAMES
FROM THE SHOW.
WE'RE LOOKING FOR THE M.V.P.--
THE FUNNIEST PERSON.
AND THE FUNNIEST PERSON
ACTUALLY WILL LAND A ROLE
ON THE HIT UPN SHOW
"VERONICA MARS."
THIS IS DEFINITELY SOMETHING
THAT'S MORE MY ELEMENT.
HERE'S SOMETHING I CAN WIN.
FIRST GAME WE'RE GONNA PLAY
IS CALLED "GOT PROPS."
WE GIVE YOU A RANDOM PROP,
AND YOU HAVE TO
MAKE SOMETHING FUNNY OUT OF IT
WITHOUT IT BEING
THE ACTUAL OBJECT THAT IT IS.
I'M A MODEL, AND, UM,
AFTER I EAT...
(imitates retching)
I'M SUZANNE SOMERS,
AND I'M HERE TO GIVE YOU
THE THIGHMASTER.
YEAH!
MY NEW EARRINGS.
THESE ARE MY NEW HOOPS.
WHAT DO YOU THINK?
SHE'S FUNNY.
MOLLIE'S PERSONALITY
IS SO MUCH DIFFERENT THAN
WHAT THE JUDGES ARE SEEING--
LIKE, SHE'S HELLA FUNNY.
I'M CINDY CRAWFORD.
SHOULD I GET THIS MOLE REMOVED?
YEAH!
ALL RIGHT, GUYS,
NOW THIS NEXT GAME
IS CALLED "QUESTIONS."
THE "QUESTIONS" GAME--
YOU WOULD ASK A QUESTION,
AND THEN THE PERSON
WOULD ASK A QUESTION BACK.
A TV AND A REMOTE.
WHY DO YOU CHANGE ME
ALL THE TIME?
(bell dings)
WHY IS YOUR ANTENNA
ALL CROOKED?
JOB INTERVIEW.
I'M SORRY, YOU DON'T HAVE
THE RIGHT QUALIFICATIONS.
(buzzer)
YOU GOTTA ASK QUESTIONS.
OH, SEE, THIS IS CONF--
MAN, I...
THE GAME IS CALLED
"QUESTIONS."
JADE--SHE JUST SUCKS
AT ALL THE STUFF THAT WE DO.
START IT ALL OVER--
WHAT, WHERE, WHEN AND WHY.
WHENEVER YOU START
WITH ONE OF THOSE,
YOU GON' BE GOOD.
ALL RIGHT, MAN. ALL RIGHT.
I'M-A GIVE YOU ONE
WHERE YOU FIGURE IT OUT--
A RICH MAN AND A POOR MAN.
MY... IS BIGGER THAN YOURS.
(buzzer)
YOU TOTALLY JUST LOST.
YOU KNOW,
EVEN THOUGH IT WAS FUN,
LAUGHTER AND JOKES,
THAT WASN'T HUMOR TO ME.
I WAS JUST LIKE, "WHAT?"
(bell dings)
"WHAT?"
(dings)
NOW IT'S TIME FOR
THE WILD STYLE BATTLE.
IT'S A HIP-HOP BATTLE,
BUT WE RHYMING
WITH PUNCH LINES AND JOKES.
♪ ROSES ARE RED ♪
♪ VIOLETS ARE BLUE ♪
♪ I'M-A WIN THE TITLE ♪
♪ AND YOU? ♪
♪ YOU LOOK LIKE BOO-BOO ♪
(laughter)
THAT'S ARKANSAS FOR "CRAP."
♪ YOU A MODEL ♪
♪ I KNOW THAT ♪
♪ BUT YOU COULD AT LEAST ♪
♪ LEARN HOW TO TALK ♪
(laughter)
ALL RIGHT!
♪ YOUR WALK IS GOOD ♪
♪ YOU MIGHT NOT FALL ♪
♪ BUT YOUR HEAD'S AS SHINY ♪
♪ AS A BIG RUBBER BALL ♪
OH, GOD.
OH! OH! OH!
♪ YEAH, MY NAME IS JOANIE ♪
♪ YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN ♪
♪ IT'S ME AND THIS WHITE DUDE ♪
♪ ON THIS HERE BLACK TEAM ♪
♪ I GOT A VOLLEYBALL DIVA ♪
♪ A HOT LATINA ♪
♪ AND TWO AFRICAN QUEENS ♪
THE RAP GAME'S GOING,
AND EVERYTHING'S FUNNY "HA HA,"
AND THEN JADE GETS UP THERE
TO "RAP."
♪ MY NAME IS JADE ♪
♪ THE ACE OF SPADES ♪
♪ FURONDA, MY DEAR ♪
♪ I KNOW YOUR SKIN IS BUMPY ♪
♪ BUT MY SKIN IS FLAWLESS ♪
♪ AND YOU LOOK REALLY LUMPY ♪
OH!
NOBODY ELSE TOOK IT THERE.
LIKE, NOBODY WAS LIKE,
"YO, JADE, YOU LOOK LIKE
AN 85-YEAR-OLD WOMAN."
♪ YO, YOU'RE BLONDE ♪
♪ YOU'RE TOO TALL ♪
♪ FOR THIS INDUSTRY ♪
♪ YOU KNOW WHAT? ♪
♪ I'M IN THIS REAL... ♪
♪ AND YOU'RE NOT BECAUSE ♪
♪ LET ME TELL YOU ♪
♪ THEY'RE GONNA NOT ♪
♪ BLOW UP YOUR... ♪
ALL THE GIRLS HAVE BEEN DOING
BETTER THAN JADE HAS, YOU KNOW?
SO I DON'T KNOW, MAYBE THAT
WAS A BLOW TO HER EGO.
I FEEL LIKE JADE
TRIES TO MAKE YOU FEEL LOW
SO SHE CAN BRING HERSELF UP.
WE GOT SOME GANGSTAS!
SOME COMEDY'S SUPPOSED
TO COME IN HERE SOMEWHERE!
♪ I THINK I NEED ♪
♪ TO PUKE IN A BOTTLE ♪
♪ IF I HEAR ONE MORE THING ♪
♪ ABOUT JADE ♪
♪ THE UNDISCOVERED SUPERMODEL ♪
THAT DIDN'T RHYME.
BROOKE, YOU GOTTA...
LIKE, I'M SHY.
ONE OF MY FEARS
IS PUBLIC SPEAKING
AND ANNOUNCING.
I KNOW, BUT IT'S OKAY.
JUST GO.
I COULDN'T THINK
OF ANYTHING TO SAY,
SO I DIDN'T HAVE A GOOD TIME.
SMILE, BROOKE.
♪ YOUR IMPROV IS HORRIBLE ♪
♪ THAT GOES WITH ♪
♪ THE CHICK NEXT TO YA ♪
♪ BUT WHICH ONE OF YOU ♪
♪ HAS GOT ANOREXIA? ♪
♪ I HATE TO BUST ON YOU ♪
♪ 'CAUSE I KNOW ♪
♪ IT'S YOUR WORLD ♪
♪ HEY, MAN ♪
♪ GET RID OF YOUR "S" CURL ♪
OH!
I DON'T LIKE YOU.
YOU GUYS DID
A PHENOMENAL JOB.
GIVE YOURSELVES
A ROUND OF APPLAUSE.
GOOD JOB.
ALL RIGHT, LADIES,
THE PURPOSE OF THIS CHALLENGE
WAS, YOU KNOW, TO SEE
WHO WAS THE MOST CREATIVE.
FURONDA,
VERY SHARP, VERY QUICK.
BROOKE, I DIDN'T KNOW
WHERE YOU WAS AT.
JADE, IN IMPROV,
ONE OF THE KEY THINGS
IS TO LISTEN.
I JUST NEEDED MORE DIRECTION.
I FEEL LIKE
IF I HAD MORE DIRECTION,
I WOULD HAVE BEEN OKAY.
MOLLIE SUE,
YOUR PERSONALITY IS HUGE.
I JUST WANTED TO SEE MORE.
SARA, YOU INSTANTLY PUT IT ON.
LESLIE, I RESPECT THE WAY
YOU WENT HARD.
JOANIE, YOU HAD FUN WITH IT.
DANIELLE,
I LIKE HOW YOU KEEP IT REAL.
NNENNA, IT'S THE ACCENT
AND THE SMILE.
YOU JUST NATURALLY FUNNY.
I WAS REALLY SURPRISED.
ALTHOUGH NNENNA IS DEALING
WITH THE DRAMA
WITH HER BOYFRIEND,
SHE REMAINED FOCUSED.
SO ULTIMATELY,
WHO HAD THE BEST IMPROV SKILLS
AND WAS THE MOST CREATIVE
AND THE QUICKEST,
I WOULD
DEFINITELY HAVE TO SAY...
FURONDA.
YOU HAVE LANDED A ROLE
ON UPN's HIT SERIES
"VERONICA MARS."
THAT AIN'T IT!
YOU GET A BONUS PRIZE THAT
YOU AND A FRIEND WILL ENJOY.
SO GO AHEAD.
I'M GONNA LET YOU
PICK A FRIEND
BEFORE I TELL YOU
WHAT THE PRIZE IS.
I VOLUNTEER. LOOK.
JADE AND I ARE NOT FRIENDS.
WE'RE NOT FRIENDS.
- WHO'D YOU PICK?
- NNENNA.
SO YOU GUYS JUST LANDED
YOUR OWN NATIONWIDE P.S.A.
YES!
PUBLIC SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENT.
PUBLIC SERVICE
ANNOUNCEMENT.
- SHE KNOWS WHAT IT IS.
- GOOD WITH THE ACRONYM.
THIS IS EXACTLY
WHAT I WANT TO DO
WITH MY SUPERMODEL
STATUS AND FAME.
I WANT PEOPLE TO TAKE NOTICE
OF THINGS THAT ARE
GOING ON IN THE WORLD.
WHY ARE YOU SUCH A BITCH,
JADE?
I'M EMBARRASSED FOR HER.
I REALLY AM.
I AM, TOO.
I'M LIKE, "A,"
YOU WERE THE ONLY ONE CUSSING.
"B," YOU WERE THE ONLY ONE
WHO WAS, LIKE, ACTUALLY
ATTACKING PEOPLE LIKE...
EXACTLY.
YOU SAID
I DON'T DESERVE TO BE HERE.
LIKE, YOU KNOW?
YOU'RE THE ONE, LIKE,
YOU'RE TAKING LOW BLOWS.
SHE SURE AS HELL DOESN'T ACT
LIKE SHE'S ALMOST 30.
♪♪♪
EVERYBODY THAT MEETS ME
FOR THE FIRST TIME
THINKS I'M, LIKE, A BITCH.
THEY THINK I'M ARROGANT.
EVERYBODY THAT KNOWS ME
KNOWS I'M NOT LIKE THAT.
I'M LIKE THE REALEST INDIVIDUAL.
IF YOU'RE A REAL PERSON,
AND A NICE PERSON...
I'M VERY REAL.
WHY WOULD YOU DO THAT?
AT WILD 'N OUT,
I THOUGHT THAT JADE
WENT WAY TOO FAR.
YOU KEEP ON GOING
OFF ON THIS NICENESS-NESS.
IT'S NOT ABOUT THAT.
YOU'RE LIKE,
"I'M SO POSITIVE.
I'M SO THIS, I'M SO THAT."
BUT THAT'S A FACADE
YOU GOT GOING ON,
AND I DON'T KNOW--
A FACADE?
WHAT THE HELL IS A FACADE?
A FACADE. AND THAT'S--
FACADE?
FACADE.
MAN, MY LIFE STORY,
I NEED TO WRITE A BOOK.
AND MAYBE ONE DAY, I WILL,
AND YOU SHOULD READ IT.
Look at you
ripping my heart out.
Why can't you love me?
WELL, YOUR LOVE SEEMS TO BE
CAUSING ME PAIN RIGHT NOW.
NNENNA'S HOLDING A MONOPOLY
ON THE PHONE RIGHT NOW,
SO THIS IS--IT'S NOT COOL.
LIKE, LAST NIGHT,
SHE WAS ON THE PHONE TILL 1:00.
NNENNA IS PERCEIVED AS BEING
THIS NICE, SWEET GIRL.
AND SHE'S NOT.
MAYBE SHE'S 120% BOOK SMART,
AND, LIKE,
4% COMMON SENSE SMART.
WELL, I KNOW PEOPLE LIKE THAT,
AND I'M JUST LIKE,
"WHY DON'T YOU GET IT?"
Go to bed!
You ruined your chance!
Go get the last thing
you've got left--
the only thing
I can wish for you now.
♪♪♪
FURONDA AND NNENNA WON
A PUBLIC SERVICE ANNOUNCEMENT,
SO WE GO TO THIS GORGEOUS HOUSE
ON TOP OF THE HILL
WITH THIS BEAUTIFUL VIEW
AND MEET THIS WOMAN
NAMED MARVELYN.
I WORK FOR
AN H.I.V.-A.I.D.S. ORGANIZATION
IN NASHVILLE, TENNESSEE,
BY THE NAME OF NASHVILLE CARES.
I'M H.I.V.-POSITIVE.
I'M 21 YEARS OLD.
I'VE NEVER PERSONALLY
SAT ACROSS,
OR EVEN KNOWN SOMEONE
WHO HAD H.I.V.
I WAS INFECTED WITH H.I.V.
WHEN I WAS ONLY 19 YEARS OLD
THROUGH UNPROTECTED SEX.
I AM A SPOKESPERSON BECAUSE
I CAN GO OUT
AND SHARE MY STORY.
BUT YOU ALL AS MODELS,
PEOPLE LOOK UP TO YOU.
YOU CAN DO SOMETHING AS WELL.
SO WHO WON
THE CHALLENGE YESTERDAY?
AND THE FRIEND?
WHO DID YOU CHOOSE?
YOU ALL WILL BE DOING A P.S.A.
THAT WILL RUN NATIONALLY
WITH UPN AFFILIATES
AND THE UPN.COM WEBSITE.
COME THIS WAY.
ACTION!
DID YOU KNOW THAT HALF
OF ALL NEW H.I.V. INFECTIONS
ARE AMONG PEOPLE UNDER 25?
HAVING A P.S.A. AND BEING ABLE
TO ACTUALLY SPEAK OUT
ON THE ISSUE...
TO HAVE THE OPPORTUNITY
WAS JUST OVERWHELMING.
I MEAN, IT'S AWESOME.
IT'S SO AWESOME.
♪♪♪
DID YOU KNOW THAT HALF
OF ALL NEW H.I.V. INFECTIONS
ARE AMONG PEOPLE UNDER 25?
DID YOU KNOW
ONE IN FOUR AMERICANS
WITH H.I.V. DOESN'T KNOW IT?
YOU CAN'T TELL
IF YOU HAVE H.I.V.
BY HOW YOU LOOK.
ONLY WAY TO KNOW FOR SURE
IS TO GET TESTED.
BE SMART. BE SAFE.
BE BEAUTIFUL.
TO FIND A TESTING SITE
IN YOUR COMMUNITY...
VISIT knowhivaids.org.
♪♪♪
GOOD MORNING.
HI, I'M JAMES.
I'M FURONDA. WHAT'S UP?
WELCOME TO "VERONICA MARS."
THANK YOU.
THIS IS LIKE
AN AMAZING EXPERIENCE
TO BE ON THE SET
OF A HIT TV SHOW.
TODAY, MY SCENE--I'M BEVERLY.
I'M GONNA BE THE ADMINISTRATIVE
ASSISTANT TO WOODY,
AND I'M GONNA BE WORKING
WITH STEVE GUTTENBERG.
I'M GONNA BE A MOVIE STAR!
YOU'RE IN.
JUST LIKE YOU.
IT'S EASY--YOU JUST GOTTA
KNOW YOUR LINES,
DON'T HIT THE FURNITURE,
AND ALWAYS MAKE SURE,
AFTER YOU'VE EATEN--CRUMBS.
-OH.
- THAT'S IT.
- AM I OKAY?
- YEAH, YOU'RE FINE.
- OKAY.
- THAT'S IT.
THAT'S ALL IT TAKES.
WHEN HE SAYS, "PROPERTY VALUES
WILL BOUNCE BACK,"
JUST KNOCK ON THE DOOR AND SAY,
"EXCUSE ME, SIR."
OKAY.
ACTION!
MR. GOODMAN?
LOGAN ECHOLLS.
THE GROUNDLINGS IMPROV
HELPED ME A LOT TODAY
BECAUSE I COMMITTED
TO THE CHARACTER THAT I WAS.
I'M A SECRETARY. I'M BEVERLY.
AND IN MY MIND,
I COMMITTED TO THAT.
WE JUST NEED THIS MAIL
SEPARATED INTO "PRO"
AND "ANTI" INCORPORATION PILES.
I'VE GOT A LETTER OPENER
YOU CAN BORROW.
CUT! TERRIFIC, FURONDA.
BRAVO! BRAVO! BRAVO! BRAVO!
THIS IS SUCH
A GOOD OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE.
I CAN'T NAME NAMES,
BUT I'M SURE THAT
THERE ARE SOME OF THE GIRLS
IN THE HOUSE THAT ARE JEALOUS
BECAUSE THEY WISH
THEY WERE IN MY POSITION TODAY.
♪♪♪
YOU GUYS, TYRA'S MIZZAIL.
"A MODEL'S LIFE IS VERY BUSY.
"CAN YOU CRAM A WHOLE PARTY
INTO 30 SECONDS?"
YES, I CAN. OBSERVE.
♪♪♪
WE GET TO THIS
AMAZING ARCHITECTURAL BEAUTY
IN THE HILLS,
AND WE'RE JUST LIKE,
"WHAT'S GOING ON?"
- HELLO.
- HI.
SO WHAT HAVE YOU GIRLS
BEEN LEARNING ABOUT THIS WEEK?
IMPROV.
IMPROV--
THAT'S A VERY IMPORTANT THING
FOR A MODEL TO HAVE
UNDER HER BELT.
NOW TODAY, YOU GIRLS ARE GOING
TO DO A COMMERCIAL
FOR COVER GIRL
CLEAN LIQUID MAKEUP,
AND THE COMMERCIAL
WILL BE IMPROVISED.
THERE IS NO PHOTO SHOOT
THIS WEEK.
IT'S ACTUALLY A COMMERCIAL.
I'M REALLY, REALLY,
REALLY, REALLY NERVOUS.
NOW I'M GONNA INTRODUCE YOU
TO MIKE.
MIKE IS A VERY TALENTED
DIRECTOR AND CINEMATOGRAPHER.
MORNING, LADIES.
JUST DO YOUR BEST TO LOOK GOOD
WHILE STAYING ON YOUR TOES.
♪♪♪
IT'S GOT NOXZEMA IN IT,
SO IT'S NOT GONNA
CLOG YOUR PORES.
ACTUALLY, IT LOOKS LIKE
YOU'RE AN AIRLINE STEWARDESS.
(laughing)
FOR A GAY AIRLINE.
ALL RIGHT,
SO I'M GONNA GIVE YOU
ALL YOUR LINES.
NOW THESE TWO LINES
YOU HAVE TO LAND
IN YOUR COMMERCIAL.
EVERYTHING ELSE
IS IMPROVISATION.
YOU'RE JUST REACTING
TO THE THINGS AROUND YOU.
YOU GUYS ARE GONNA ONLY
HAVE TWO TAKES EACH.
EVERYONE SHOULD AT LEAST KNOW
THE MAIN THING IN HERE, RIGHT?
WHAT IS IT?
EASY, BREEZY, BEAUTIFUL--
COVERGIRL.
I'M NOT SHY
IN FRONT OF THE CAMERA,
SO I FEEL THIS IS
A GREAT OPPORTUNITY FOR ME.
IT'S JUST SOMETHING THAT
"EASY, BREEZY, BEAUTIFUL
COVERGIRL" NEEDS TO SEE.
YOU'RE WALKING BASICALLY
UP AROUND THESE STAIRS
ALONG THE SIDE OF THE POOL
TO THAT MARKER, WHERE YOU--
30 SECONDS?
YEAH, IN 30 SECONDS.
THE TWO DELIVERABLE LINES
ARE AT THE END.
RIGHT.
EVERYTHING ELSE BEFORE THAT
IS ON YOU.
AND JUST REMEMBER THAT
THE WHOLE TIME, YOU WANNA REALLY
ENGAGE THE CAMERA.
ROLLING SOUND,
ROLLING CAMERA.
ACTION!
OH, THANK YOU.
WHEN YOU'RE OUT ON THE TOWN,
DON'T BE A WALLFLOWER.
MAKE SURE YOU PUT
YOUR BEST FACE FORWARD.
HEY, EVERYONE.
WE HAD 30 SECONDS TO, LIKE,
WALK UP THE STAIRS, AROUND,
BY THE POOL AND THEN
STOP AND LAND OUR LINES.
THANK YOU, SIR.
JUST WHAT I NEED.
SHEER LIGHTWEIGHT COVERAGE.
DERMATOLOGIST-TESTED.
CLEAN LIQUID MAKEUP.
ONLY FROM EASY, BREEZY,
BEAUTIFUL COVERGIRL.
AND CUT!
YOU HELD THE PRODUCT
OUT OF FRAME.
YOU WERE DOWN HERE.
AND DO YOU REALLY WANNA
SELL FOUNDATION
WITH AN ALCOHOLIC BEVERAGE?
NO.
I SHOULD HAVE BEEN THINKING,
YOU KNOW,
THE IMAGE OF A COVER GIRL--
YOU KNOW, NO ALCOHOL.
I FAILED THE TEST.
ALL RIGHT, YOU'RE GONNA BE
ON THE FOURTH STEP HERE.
FURONDA'S EITHER GONNA
FALL FLAT OR DO IT.
THERE'S GONNA BE
NO IN BETWEEN WITH HER.
HOW YOU DOING?
HEY! HOW'S IT GOING?
COVERGIRL MAKEUP.
I JUST THOUGHT ABOUT
SOME OF THE TIPS WE LEARNED
AT GROUNDLINGS.
COMMITMENT IS
THE NUMBER ONE RULE OF IMPROV.
YOU HAVE TO FEEL IT
IN ORDER FOR IT
TO LOOK REAL ON CAMERA.
PARTIES ARE SO UNPREDICTABLE.
BUT YOUR MAKEUP
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE.
THAT'S A GOOD LINE.
EASY, BREEZY, BEAUTIFUL--
COVERGIRL.
AND CUT!
PERSONALLY,
I KNOW I DID GOOD TODAY,
SO THAT WORKS FOR ME.
- THANKS.
- YOU'RE WELCOME.
I LOVE COMING TO LOS ANGELES.
I LOVE ENTERTAINING MY FRIENDS.
I DON'T KNOW
WHAT I WAS TALKING ABOUT.
I COULD HAVE BEEN
GIVING A RECIPE
FOR, LIKE, BLUEBERRY MUFFINS.
YOU GUYS GONNA BE HERE
ALL NIGHT?
OH, WAIT. LOOK, LOOK.
SHE STOPPED TO HAVE A PARTY.
HAD NOTHING TO DO
WITH MAKEUP.
LIKE, TOTALLY MADE A FOOL
OUT OF MYSELF.
EASY, BREEZY, BEAUTIFUL--
COVERGIRL.
AND CUT!
SMILE!
YOU'RE SELLING A PRODUCT.
- I DID MY BEST.
- THANKS.
ON A NIGHT ON THE TOWN,
COVERGIRL HELPS ME LOOK MY BEST.
I REALLY WASN'T NERVOUS.
I WASN'T NERVOUS AT ALL
IN THERE, YOU KNOW.
AND THEN, OF COURSE,
ONCE YOU GET IN THERE,
YOU KIND OF HAVE
THOSE BUTTERFLIES.
SHEER, LIGHTWEIGHT COVERAGE.
DERMATOLOGIST-TESTED.
CLEAN LIQUID MAKEUP.
ONLY FROM EASY, BREEZY,
BEAUTIFUL COVERGIRL.
CUT!
WHEN YOU GOT TO THE END,
IT SOUNDS LIKE
YOU WERE SELLING
PHARMACEUTICALS.
- OKAY.
- YOU KNOW WHEN THEY SAY,
"YOU MAY HAVE DIARRHEA,
BLAH, BLAH, BLAH"?
SO DON'T SELL ME
THE SIDE EFFECTS.
- MOLLIE, YOU READY, MISS?
- I'M READY.
IN THESE KIND OF THINGS
THAT ARE MORE MY ELEMENT,
I NEED TO JUST
BLOW EVERYONE AWAY
AND SHOW THEM MY PERSONALITY.
ACTION!
YOU KNOW, OF COURSE,
YOU THINK,
"I CAN DO A LITTLE IMPROV
AND THEN REMEMBER MY LINES."
BUT YOU GET OUT THERE,
AND IT'S LIKE,
"SHOULD I TAKE THE DRINK
FROM THIS GUY?
SHOULD I TALK TO THESE PEOPLE?"
IT'S LIKE ALL OF A SUDDEN,
EVERYTHING'S DIFFERENT,
AND YOUR LINES
ARE NOWHERE TO BE FOUND.
SHEER... LONG-LASTING...
DERMATOLOGIST-TESTED...
YOU MISSED A LINE,
AND THERE WAS NOTHING ENGAGING
ABOUT THAT DELIVERY.
I'M PRETTY DISAPPOINTED
BECAUSE I'M NOT THIS PERSON.
I HAVE TO SOMEHOW STEP OUT OF
WHATEVER'S HOLDING ME BACK
BECAUSE I HAVE TO WIN THIS.
I'M READY.
YOU READY? OKAY.
ACTION!
EVERY WOMAN IS LOOKING FOR
A SPOT OF PERFECTION.
SO WHY NOT START WITH
THAT PERFECTION ON YOUR FACE?
WE HAD TO TALK, LIKE,
THE WHOLE WAY UP THERE,
AND IT'S MORE DIFFICULT THAN
WHAT YOU THINK IT'S GONNA BE.
DERMATOLOGIST-TESTED,
LIQUID...
I AM TRIPPING.
IF THERE IS ONE THING
THAT YOU HAVE TO REMEMBER
ABOUT COVERGIRL, WHAT IS IT?
EASY, BREEZY, BEAUTIFUL
COVERGIRL.
WHAT'S WRONG WITH ME?
ALL RIGHT, TAKE TWO.
EASY, BREEZY, BEAUTIFUL
COVERGIRL.
IS THAT A WAY
TO SELL A PRODUCT?
MNH-MNH.
THAT'S A WAY
TO SELL A PRODUCT.
THERE'S A LOT GOING ON,
BUT YOU HAVE TO DRAW
THE VIEWER'S EYE TO YOU.
BEING A MODEL IS A JOB.
IF I HAVE A DUTY AT HAND,
I FOCUS AND LEAVE WHATEVER
WORRIES YOU HAVE AT HOME
AT HOME.
LADIES, WHATEVER YOUR AGE IS,
FOR ALL OCCASIONS,
COVERGIRL MAKEUP
IS THE WAY TO GO.
EASY, BREEZY, BEAUTIFUL
COVERGIRL.
AND CUT!
YOU WERE RELATING THE PARTY
AND THE BRAND.
THIS WAS VERY IMPRESSIVE.
HOW'D YOU GUYS DO?
SHE CAME IN
WITH A SMILE ON HER FACE, LIKE,
"HOW'D YOU GUYS DO?
I DID GREAT!"
WE'RE ALL LIKE...
"JUST PLEASE GO
"IN ANOTHER ROOM RIGHT NOW,
BECAUSE THAT'S NOT
WHAT I WANNA HEAR."
WHAT?
(laughter)
I REALLY DON'T QUESTION
THE OTHER GIRLS
ABOUT HOW THEY FEEL ABOUT ME,
'CAUSE I DON'T CARE TO KNOW.
OH, MY GOODNESS GRACIOUS.
YOUR HEART IS, LIKE, RACING.
YOUR PULSE IS GOING,
"BOOM, BOOM, BOOM."
ARE YOU OKAY?
ARE YOU SURE?
I DON'T WANT YOU
TO PASS OUT OR ANYTHING.
NO, NO, NO, NO.
WHY ARE YOU CRYING?
I JUST GET REALLY NERVOUS,
THAT'S ALL.
OH, MY GOSH,
YOU'RE MAKING ME NERVOUS.
THERE'S REALLY NOT
ROOM FOR MISTAKES,
AND SO JUST ONE SMALL MISTAKE
CAN GET YOU
OUT OF THE COMPETITION.
ACTION!
OH, MY GOSH.
SHE SAID, "OH, GOSH."
NOT GOOD.
WHAT'S GOING ON?
I JUST LOVE
WEARING COVERGIRL.
IT'S JUST SO... NICE TO WEAR.
SHEER... LIGHT COVERAGE MAKEUP.
AND CUT!
I THINK WHAT HAPPENED IS
YOU GOT SO CAUGHT UP
IN THE IMPROVISATION
THAT YOU FORGOT THE FINAL LINE.
MM-HMM. I'M SORRY.
DON'T APOLOGIZE.
YOU LEARN FROM IT, ALL RIGHT?
- OKAY. THANK YOU.
- OKAY, THANKS.
I DIDN'T DO WELL LAST WEEK
SINCE I DID NOT GOOD AT ALL.
THIS WEEK,
I THINK, MORE THAN LIKELY,
I'LL PROBABLY BE GOING HOME.
HOW'D YOU DO, BROOKE?
I DON'T WANT
TO TALK ABOUT IT.
BROOKE...
I DON'T WANT
TO TALK ABOUT IT.
I DON'T WANT TO TALK ABOUT IT.
BROOKEY, MAN--
SHE'S SO SENTIMENTAL,
'CAUSE THAT'S JUST HER NATURE.
SHE JUST BREAKS.
IT'S UP TO YOU TO IMPROVISE
AND SELL YOURSELF.
YOU'VE SEEN
COVERGIRL COMMERCIALS.
YOU KNOW HOW THEY GO?
I HAVE A PERSONALITY,
YOU KNOW, I HAVE STYLE,
YOU KNOW, I HAVE CLASS.
AND I'M JUST ME, AND I'M REAL.
ACTION!
♪♪♪
SHE DOESN'T QUITE
GRASP THE FACT THAT
SHE'S GOT TO IMPROVISE
IN THIS SCENE.
IT WAS 30 SECONDS
OF ME LISTENING TO HER HEELS
CLOP ON THE CONCRETE.
THIS WAS YOU...
WHAT WAS THAT?
IT WAS MY ENTRANCE.
YOU WERE
MAKING YOUR ENTRANCE...
BUT YOU DIDN'T
IMPROVISE ANYTHING.
TAKE TWO.
YOU GUYS LOOK FABULOUS.
OH, WHAT A PARTY!
OH, MY GOSH!
THE SECOND TIME,
I JUST TOOK MY TIME,
TALKING, "HEY, GIRL!"
WONDERFUL, FABULOUS.
SHE'S A DRAG QUEEN.
OKAY. THIS IS...
OKAY.
LIGHTWEIGHT MAKEUP...
(bleep)
CUT!
GIRLFRIEND,
GIRLS DON'T SAY THAT.
MAN, I CAN'T BELIEVE
I WENT BLANK.
I CURSED, YOU KNOW,
WHICH WAS A BAD THING
I SHOULDN'T HAVE DONE,
BUT IT'S JUST LIKE...
I COULDN'T BELIEVE
I FORGOT MY LINES.
SO ARE YOU READY
TO BE A COVER GIRL?
- YES.
- YOU ARE?
I WOULD LOVE TO BE
A COVER GIRL.
I DIDN'T KNOW IT,
'CAUSE I DIDN'T HEAR ANYTHING
ABOUT COVERGIRL.
IF I HAD ONE MORE TAKE,
I KNOW I WOULD HAVE ACED IT,
BECAUSE I JUST NEEDED
A LITTLE BIT MORE DIRECTION,
THAT'S ALL.
TYRA MAIL!
LIKE, THE GROUP OF GIRLS
WE'RE DOWN TO NOW,
EVERY SINGLE PERSON CAN WIN.
"TOMORROW
YOU WILL MEET WITH THE JUDGES.
"ONLY EIGHT WILL CONTINUE ON
IN THE HOPES OF BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
OH, BOY.
YEAH.
LIKE, EVERYONE
HAD SOME NEGATIVES
WITH THEIR COMMERCIAL.
EVERYONE'S A LITTLE CONCERNED.
IT'S LIKE WE ALL THINK
WE'RE GOING HOME.
I ACCEPT THE FACT THAT
I WILL BE SENT HOME TOMORROW
BECAUSE I'M NOT "STRONG ENOUGH"
JUST BECAUSE I CRY.
I THINK JADE
SHOULD BE THE MOST NERVOUS
BECAUSE SHE SWORE.
IT'S NOT EVEN HOT.
I REALLY HAVE WHAT IT TAKES
TO BE AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL,
BABY.
DON'T YOU GET IT TWISTED.
AND I KNOW A LOT OF THE GIRLS
ARE INTIMIDATED,
AND THEY SEE THAT.
THEY, LIKE, YOU KNOW...
I AM A THREAT.
♪♪♪
HELLO, LADIES.
HEY.
- REMEMBER THAT?
- UH-HUH.
GOODNESS.
SCARED THE LIFE OUT OF ME.
SCARED ME. MY HEART STOPPED.
WELL, EARLIER THIS WEEK,
I DID A FAKE FAINTING,
AND ONE OF US HAD
A VERY EMOTIONAL RESPONSE,
WHICH I DID NOT WANT TO HAPPEN,
AND I APOLOGIZE
FOR PUTTING YOU THROUGH THAT.
SO YOU LEARNED ALL ABOUT ACTING.
AND YOU GUYS ACTUALLY GOT TO
WILD OUT WITH NICK CANNON.
BUT NOW IT'S TIME
FOR ANOTHER CUT.
AND YOU KNOW ABOUT
THE AMAZING PRIZES.
THE FIRST IS A MODELING CONTRACT
WITH TOP INTERNATIONAL
MODELING MANAGEMENT COMPANY
FORD MODELS,
A SPREAD IN "ELLE" MAGAZINE,
WHICH WILL BE SHOT BY
WORLD-RENOWNED PHOTOGRAPHER
GILLES BENSIMON
AND A $100,000 CONTRACT
WITH COVERGIRL COSMETICS.
AND YOU KNOW OUR JUDGES.
THE FIRST IS THE NOTED
FASHION PHOTOGRAPHER
MR. NIGEL BARKER.
HEY, LADIES.
FABULOUS DIVA RUNWAY COACH
MISS J.
LEGENDARY FASHION ICON TWIGGY.
HELLO.
AND MICHAEL ROSENTHAL,
WHO IS YOUR COMMERCIAL DIRECTOR
THAT DIRECTED
YOUR COVERGIRL COMMERCIAL,
AND HE'S ALSO A PHOTOGRAPHER
THAT HAS DONE GORGEOUS WORK
FOR "AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL."
ALL RIGHTY, SO NOW IT'S TIME FOR
YOUR INDIVIDUAL EVALUATIONS,
AND AFTER THAT,
THE JUDGES WILL DELIBERATE
AND WILL DETERMINE WHICH OF YOU
WILL BE ELIMINATED.
WE RANDOMLY DRAW NAMES,
AND, MOLLIE SUE, YOU'RE FIRST.
ALL RIGHT, MOLLIE,
SO YOU HAD A COMMERCIAL
FOR COVERGIRL WHERE YOU HAD TO
BE THE LIFE OF THE PARTY.
SO LET'S TAKE A LOOK
AT YOUR BEST TAKE.
♪♪♪
FOR A LATE NIGHT,
I WANT SOMETHING
LIGHT AND HASSLE-FREE.
SHEER...
LONG LASTING...
DERMATOLOGIST-TESTED.
EASY, BREEZY, BEAUTIFUL
COVERGIRL.
THAT WASN'T
A MODEL'S PERFORMANCE.
THERE WAS NO PASSION
IN YOUR EYES.
YOU DIDN'T DELIVER
THE CORRECT LINE AT THE END,
BUT YOU WERE VERY CONCISE
IN HOW YOU SPOKE.
BUT I THINK INSTEAD OF
ENGAGING THE VIEWER, YOU MAY...
SCARY.
MAKE THEM BACK OFF
A LITTLE BIT.
IT WAS ALMOST LIKE
YOU WERE SELLING MACE.
"YOU WANNA GET PEOPLE
ON YOUR WAY?"
LIKE...
ALL RIGHT, DANIELLE, SO YOU HAD
A COVERGIRL COMMERCIAL
FOR FOUNDATION,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST TAKE.
THANK YOU.
(laughs)
YOU TOOK A DRINK AND THEN
PUT IT BACK DOWN ON THE THING.
HE WAS GONNA WALK AWAY,
AND I WAS LIKE, "MNH-MNH."
EVERY WOMAN IS LOOKING FOR
A SPOT OF PERFECTION.
SO WHY NOT START WITH
THAT PERFECTION ON YOUR FACE?
EASY, BREEZY, BEAUTIFUL
COVERGIRL.
ALL RIGHT, DANIELLE,
SO YOU KNOW ABOUT THE ACCENT.
(Southern accent)
"PERFECTION."
(normal voice)
YOU HAVE TO REALLY STUDY
THE OTHER GIRLS
THAT HAVE
THE NEWSCASTER ACCENT.
JUST THE NORMAL ACCENT
WHERE NO MATTER WHAT CITY
YOU'RE IN, IT'S PRETTY MUCH
A STANDARD ACCENT.
THAT'S EXTREMELY IMPORTANT
IN DOING A COMMERCIAL.
I WILL WORK ON THAT.
UP NEXT IS FURONDA.
HERE'S YOUR BEST TAKE.
WOW,
PARTIES ARE SO UNPREDICTABLE.
BUT YOUR MAKEUP
DOESN'T HAVE TO BE.
EASY, BREEZY, BEAUTIFUL
COVERGIRL.
IT WAS A LITTLE
OVER THE TOP AT THE END,
BUT AT LEAST YOU WENT FOR IT.
I JUST DIDN'T LIKE
THE THREE POSES WITH THE TAG.
"UH, BREEZY, BEAUTIFUL."
AND YOU NEED TO RELAX
YOUR EYEBROWS.
YOU GOT NERVOUS,
AND YOUR EYEBROWS
WENT UP INTO THE SKY,
SO YOU JUST NEED TO RELAX.
BUT OTHER THAN THAT,
I THOUGHT YOU DID
A REALLY GOOD JOB.
AND FURONDA WAS
THE CHALLENGE WINNER.
NICK CANNON SAID THAT
YOU WERE VERY SHARP
AND HAD A QUICK WIT
AT "WILD 'N OUT."
SO, CONGRATULATIONS.
WELL DONE.
AND YOU'RE GONNA BE
ON "VERONICA MARS."
ALL RIGHTY, SO, BROOKE,
YOU HAD A COMMERCIAL,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST TAKE.
I JUST LOVE
WEARING COVERGIRL.
IT'S JUST SO NICE TO WEAR.
MMM...
SHEER, LIGHT COVERAGE MAKEUP.
(sighs)
THAT WAS DREADFUL.
YOU WERE "BABBLING BROOKE."
YOU GOT CAMERA-SHY,
OR YOU GOT STAGE FRIGHT.
I STARTED WORRYING SO MUCH
ABOUT MY IMPROV-ING,
THAT WHEN I GOT TO THE END,
I JUST FROZE.
YEAH, I'D SAY YOUR NERVES
GET THE BETTER OF YOU,
AND I KNOW BECAUSE I WAS
REALLY, REALLY, REALLY SHY
WHEN I FIRST STARTED.
IT'S NOT ABOUT SHY.
SO MANY ACTRESSES ARE
THE MOST SHY PEOPLE
IN THE WORLD.
IT'S ABOUT STAGE FRIGHT.
THERE'S A DIFFERENCE.
ALL RIGHT, NNENNA,
SO YOU HAD A COMMERCIAL,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST TAKE.
FOR LADIES,
WHATEVER YOUR AGE IS,
FOR ALL OCCASIONS,
COVERGIRL MAKEUP
IS THE WAY TO GO.
EASY, BREEZY, BEAUTIFUL
COVERGIRL.
OOH, NNENNA WAS TAKING
NO PRISONERS ON THAT ONE.
YOU LEFT A WAKE OF PARTYGOERS
BEHIND YOU.
BUT IT DID REMIND ME
OF A REAL MAKEUP COMMERCIAL
WHERE YOU'RE JUST
KIND OF RUNNING,
AND IT'S A FRENETIC PACE
AND YOU'RE GOING.
YOU COULD HAVE DONE IT
A BIT MORE GRACEFUL.
YOU COULD HAVE DONE IT AND BEEN
MORE SORT OF, YOU KNOW,
THESE ARE YOUR GUESTS,
THESE ARE YOUR FRIENDS.
YOU GOTTA WALK THROUGH AND GO,
"EXCUSE ME."
ALL RIGHTY,
UP NEXT IS JOANIE.
I LOVE COMING TO LOS ANGELES.
I LOVE ENTERTAINING MY FRIENDS.
COVERGIRL GIVES ME CONFIDENCE
TO GO OUT
AND MAKE IT
THROUGH THE DAY.
(chuckles)
EASY, BREEZY, BEAUTIFUL
COVERGIRL.
JOANIE, I THINK YOU'VE REALLY
GOTTA REALIZE WHERE YOU ARE.
YOU'RE IN A FABULOUS HOUSE,
AND YOU ARE SELLING COVERGIRL.
SO THIS MEANS
THAT YOU GOTTA HAVE
SOME ELEMENT OF SOPHISTICATION.
SO, LESLIE,
YOU HAD A COMMERCIAL
WHERE YOU HAD TO AD-LIB.
HERE'S YOUR BEST TAKE.
ON A NIGHT ON THE TOWN,
COVERGIRL HELPS ME LOOK MY BEST.
HOW YOU GUYS DOING?
SHEER LIGHTWEIGHT COVERAGE.
DERMATOLOGIST-TESTED.
CLEAN LIQUID MAKEUP.
ONLY FROM EASY, BREEZY,
BEAUTIFUL COVERGIRL.
WALKING THROUGH,
THERE WAS JUST SOMETHING
VERY MODEL-Y ABOUT YOU.
I LIKE THAT A LOT.
EXCEPT WHEN YOU DELIVERED
THE TAG LINE,
YOU JUST GOT KIND OF MEAN.
CAMERA JUST LOVES YOU.
YOU REALLY NEED TO BRING THAT.
'CAUSE I'VE NEVER SEEN THAT
IN THIS ROOM.
NEVER.
ALL RIGHTY, UP NEXT IS SARA.
HERE'S YOUR BEST TAKE.
WHEN YOU'RE OUT ON THE TOWN,
DON'T BE A WALLFLOWER.
MAKE SURE YOU PUT
YOUR BEST FACE FORWARD.
SHEER LIGHTWEIGHT COVERAGE.
DERMATOLOGIST-TESTED.
CLEAN LIQUID MAKEUP.
IS THAT THE COCKTAIL
OR THE...
FIRST OF ALL,
TO HAVE A DRINK IN YOUR HAND
AT ALL IS BAD, BUT TO HAVE IT
AS HIGH AS THE PRODUCT
AND BOTH OF 'EM
ARE HALFWAY OUT OF FRAME,
THAT'S A BIG ERROR.
LIKE, YOU LOOK LIKE
A REAL COVERGIRL
IN A COVERGIRL COMMERCIAL.
IT STARTED STRONG.
YOU JUST HAVE TO END
JUST AS STRONG AS YOU START.
ALL RIGHTY, JADE,
SO YOU HAD A COMMERCIAL,
AND HERE'S YOUR BEST TAKE.
HEY, GIRLS.
YOU GUYS LOOK FABULOUS.
WONDERFUL, FABULOUS.
OKAY. THIS IS...
OKAY, UM...
COVERAGE...
YOU GUYS USED MY WORST ONE.
YOU'RE SAYING
THIS IS YOUR WORST ONE?
BECAUSE THE OTHER ONE,
I DID THE LINES PERFECTLY.
AND MY IMPROV-ING WASN'T GOOD.
ON THE FIRST TAKE, THERE WAS
VERY LITTLE INTERACTION
WITH THE BACKGROUND.
AND ALSO, THERE WAS REALLY
NO SPEAKING.
- ALL WE HEARD WAS FOOTSTEPS.
- CORRECT.
YOU'RE OFTEN ONLY GIVEN
ONE CHANCE AT A CASTING
TO DELIVER YOUR LINES.
WHO DOESN'T THINK
IT WAS THEIR BEST TAKE?
BE HONEST.
YOU HAVE TO KNOW THAT YOU'RE NOT
THE ONLY PERSON
THINKING THAT RIGHT NOW.
YEAH, IT HAPPENS TO ALL OF US
IN ALL WALKS OF LIFE.
I HAVE WORKED FOR
VICTORIA'S SECRET
FOR TEN YEARS,
AND I'M LIKE,
"WHY THE HELL
DID THEY CHOOSE THAT SHOT?"
YOU'LL NEVER BE 100% HAPPY
AS A MODEL.
IT WAS JUST VERY UNNATURAL
AND PUSHING TOO HARD, LIKE,
"HEY, GIRL. MMM. AH!"
TWISTING AND TURNING AND...
YEAH, IT WAS VERY DRAGGISH.
ALL RIGHT, GUYS,
SINCE THEY DIDN'T HAVE
A PHOTO SHOOT THIS WEEK,
WE'RE GONNA LOOK AT
WHAT WE CALL STILL GRABS
FROM THE COMMERCIAL.
JOANIE.
SHE LOOKS AMAZING.
SHE'S GOT GREAT STAGE PRESENCE,
BUT SHE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND
WHY SHE'S HERE.
SHE DOESN'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT SHE'S DOING.
LESLIE.
IN THAT COMMERCIAL,
SHE DID THINGS WRONG,
AS THEY ALL DID, BUT, BLIMEY,
DID THE CAMERA LOVE HER.
BLIMEY.
JADE.
JADE HAS THE BONE STRUCTURE
TO BE A MODEL.
IF THIS WASN'T A DRAG QUEEN
WALKING THROUGH THAT PARTY,
I DON'T KNOW WHAT WAS.
"DARLING! YES! HEY, GIRL!"
PERSONALLY, I DON'T THINK
EITHER ONE OF JADE'S TAKES
WAS ANY GOOD.
SHE DON'T THINK THAT.
MOLLIE SUE.
SHE'S REALLY SMART.
DEFINITELY INTELLECTUAL.
SHE'S NOT MODELING.
SHE'S MORE LIKE
A TV PRESENTER FOR ME.
"AND THAT'S IT FOR TONIGHT,
EVERYBODY.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
I'M MOLLIE SUE."
I STILL THINK
THERE'S HOPE FOR MOLLIE SUE.
SOMETIMES SHE BORES ME,
LIKE ANOTHER GIRL
IN THIS COMPETITION.
WHO ELSE BORES YOU?
NNENNA.
YOU KNOW,
SHE'S JUST NOT PRESENT.
I FEEL LIKE
SHE'S STARTING TO GET UPSET.
I FEEL LIKE SHE WANTS TO COME
PUNCH EVERYBODY ON THE PANEL.
SARA.
SARA, TO ME, IS LIKE A DWARF
STUCK INSIDE A GIANT'S BODY.
SHE DOESN'T HAVE THAT PRESENCE.
DANIELLE.
DANIELLE JUST HAS TO
REFINE MOVEMENTS
AND WHAT SHE SAYS.
(Southern accent)
DANIELLE WAS, LIKE,
TALKIN' LIKE THIS,
AND YOU AIN'T GONNA BE
NOBODY'S COVER GIRL
TALKIN' LIKE THIS.
(normal voice)
FURONDA.
I LOVE HER PERSONALITY.
BUT SHE'S GOT NO BUST,
AND SHE'S SUPER SKINNY.
ANY ONE OF YOU KNOW
WHO DEBRA SHAW IS?
- SURE.
- PRAYING MANTIS.
THAT'S JUST HOW SHE'S BUILT.
FURONDA SHOCKED ME
IN THIS COMMERCIAL.
SHE'S ARTICULATE,
SHE MOVES WELL,
AND SHE HAS A PERSONALITY.
BROOKE.
I THINK BROOKE'S BIGGEST
FLAW IS,
SHE'S JUST REALLY FRAGILE.
SHE CAN'T SPEAK YET.
SHE'S FAR TOO QUIET.
I CAN NEVER
HEAR A WORD SHE SAYS.
STILL LOOKS LIKE A TROUT,
BUT I LOVE HER.
YES, WELL, IF THIS WAS
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP TROUT,"
THIS WOULD BE A KEEPER.
WHEN YOU ALL
LOOK AT COMMERCIALS,
IT PROBABLY LOOKS EASY,
DOESN'T IT?
BUT THIS WEEK, YOU FOUND OUT
THAT IT'S NOT SO SIMPLE.
NINE GIRLS STAND BEFORE ME,
BUT I ONLY HAVE EIGHT PHOTOS
IN MY HANDS,
AND THESE PHOTOS REPRESENT
THE EIGHT OF YOU
THAT WILL
STILL BE IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
THE FIRST NAME
THAT I'M GOING TO CALL...
FURONDA.
CONGRATULATIONS, FURONDA.
YOU DID THE BEST THIS WEEK.
AND YOU'RE STILL IN THE RUNNING
TOWARDS BECOMING
AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL.
SARA.
CONGRATULATIONS.
LESLIE. CONGRATULATIONS.
DANIELLE.
(Southern accent)
DANIELLE, NOW YOU NEED TO
GET IT TOGETHER NOW.
YOU NEED TO TALK
A LITTLE BETTER NOW,
'CAUSE YOU AIN'T GONNA GET
NO COMMERCIAL TALKING LIKE THAT.
YES, MA'AM.
(normal voice)
NNENNA.
WHY ARE YOU
SO RELIEVED, NNENNA?
I DIDN'T DO SO WELL.
I NEED TO JUST RELAX
AND TRY TO BE MORE PERSONABLE.
THERE YOU GO.
JOANIE.
CONGRATULATIONS.
UM... WHAT? HUH?
(sighs)
THANK YOU.
I DON'T HAVE TO SAY
MUCH MORE, DO I? OKAY.
WILL MOLLIE SUE AND JADE
PLEASE STEP FORWARD?
I ONLY HAVE ONE PHOTO
IN MY HANDS.
THE GIRL THAT I DO NOT CALL
MUST IMMEDIATELY
RETURN TO THE HOUSE,
PACK YOUR BELONGINGS
AND GO HOME.
MOLLIE SUE, THE REASON WHY
YOU STAND BEFORE ME RIGHT NOW
IS NOT BECAUSE
YOU TAKE BAD PICTURES.
IT'S BECAUSE OF SOMETHING
THAT WE CALL LACK OF PERSONA.
AND WHEN YOU
PRESENTED YOURSELF TODAY,
SOMETHING ABOUT IT
WAS JUST ROBOTIC.
JADE, YOU STAND BEFORE ME
RIGHT NOW
NOT BECAUSE
YOUR COMMERCIAL WAS VERY BAD.
YOU STAND BEFORE ME BECAUSE
YOU PLAY THE BLAME GAME.
YOU KNOW WHAT MICHAEL,
YOUR DIRECTOR,
SAID DURING DELIBERATIONS?
BOTH OF YOUR TAKES WERE BAD.
BOTH OF THEM.
AND THE JUDGES WERE TURNED OFF
BY YOUR ATTITUDE.
SO WHO GOES HOME?
THE GIRL THAT THEY FEEL IS
JUST NOT SHINING AS BRIGHTLY
AS SHE CAN,
OR THE GIRL THAT FEELS
LIKE SHE KNOWS IT ALL?
JADE, YOU DON'T KNOW IT ALL.
YOU DON'T KNOW IT ALL,
AND THAT'S WHY YOU
HAVE ENTERED THIS COMPETITION,
BECAUSE YOU HAVE TRIED
TO MODEL FOR SO LONG,
AND IT HASN'T HAPPENED.
SO NOW IT'S TIME TO
JUST LISTEN AND LEARN.
THANK YOU FOR
BELIEVING IN ME ONCE AGAIN.
THANK YOU, MOLLIE SUE.
I'M SO CONFUSED RIGHT NOW.
FOR JADE TO STAY OVER ME
WAS JUST CRAZY,
AND I JUST--I DIDN'T SEE IT
COMING AT ALL.
IT'S NOT EVEN BEING VOTED OFF.
IT'S BEING VOTED OFF
FOR NOT HAVING PERSONALITY.
IT'S JUST THE STRANGEST--
IT'S THE LAST REASON
IN THE WORLD
I THOUGHT I'D BE LEAVING.
YOU KNOW, AFTER THE WEEK
I'VE BEEN PROGRESSING--
LIKE, I'VE BEEN GETTING BETTER
WITH EVERYTHING WITH THE SHOOTS,
AND IT'S JUST...
I REALLY THOUGHT
I HAD THE CHANCE.
I REALLY THOUGHT,
"I CAN REALLY WIN THIS."
♪♪♪
COMING UP ON
"AMERICA'S NEXT TOP MODEL"...
THE GIRLS MEET A PAIR
OF TWIRLING TWINS.
THE SWIRL.
AND IT SENDS
SOME OF THEM TUMBLING.
A HIP-HOP PHOTO SHOOT
BRINGS OUT JADE'S WILD SIDE.
AND TENSIONS IN THE HOUSE...
BROOKE IS MAD AT YOU, MAN.
PUSH BROOKE
TO HER BOILING POINT.
YOU ARE A (bleep) BITCH,
NNENNA.